Bonjour! Le sujet d'aujourd'hui peut paraître
un peu facile, ohlala, elle parle de maladie
en pleine pandémie... Mais ça faisait un
moment que j'avais envie de m'y attaquer alors
pourquoi pas.
-Et puis pour une fois qu'on a un sujet que
Lucretia ET moi avons connu, ça se fête!
Ça va être l'occasion de se rapprocher de
renforcer nos liens, de...
-De jouer à la lèpre.
-Comment ça?!
-Reste loin de moi.
Avant de commencer, je tiens à signaler que
préparer cette vidéo n'a pas été des plus
simples. Entre les historiens qui pensent
que la lèpre n'apparaît en Europe qu'au
XIe siècle, ceux qui disent qu'elle est là
depuis l'Antiquité...
-Le camp qui dit que la majorité des européens
en était atteint et ceux qui pensent qu'ils
étaient très minoritaires...
-La discussion sur le nombre de léproseries,
sur l'exclusion ou non des lépreux...
-Bref, la lèpre est un sujet historique qui
a subi beaucoup de débats et un gros renouvellement
historiographique ces dernières décennies,
et c'est donc aux travaux les plus récents
que j'ai décidé de me fier le plus.
La lèpre est connue depuis fort longtemps,
puisqu'elle est citée dans la Bible. On en
trouve aussi une description dans un papyrus
vieux de 3500 ans. On sait maintenant qu'elle
a une souche unique, apparue au Soudan il
y a environ 100 000 ans, et diffusée ensuite
vers le Golfe persique et l'Inde.
Les historiens ont longtemps cru qu'elle n'apparaissait
en Europe qu'au bas Moyen Âge, et que jusque-là
la mention de «lèpre» recouvrait en
fait tout un tas de maladies. Il est vrai
que durant toute l'Antiquité et le Moyen
Âge on a tendance à appeler lèpre les psoriasis,
eczéma, vitiligo... Dans cette idée la maladie
aurait été ramenée lors des premières
croisades, au XIe siècle.
-On y croisait vraiment n'importe qui.
-Cette idée est par exemple véhiculée par
Voltaire, qui écrit dans son Dictionnaire
Philosophique: «Tout ce que nous gagnâmes
à la fin de nos croisades, ce fut cette gale
; et de tout ce que nous avions pris, elle
fut la seule chose qui nous resta.» Michelet
de son côté parle de «sale résidu des
croisades».
-C'est absurde, nous connaissions la lèpre
bien avant qu'elle ne vous coule.
-Effectivement, la lèpre apparaît en Grèce
vers le IVe siècle avant J.-C. Il semble
qu'elle ait été rapportée d'Orient par
les armées d'Alexandre le Grand.
-Au moins les croisés ramènent des trucs
plus utiles. Les hôpitaux, par exemple.
-De l'Égypte et de la Grèce elle passe alors
à Rome, vers le Ier siècle avant J.-C.,
via les armées de Pompée. Elle se répand
dans toute l'Europe grâce aux conquêtes
romaines et durant l'Antiquité tardive. Au
haut Moyen-Âge, les contacts de plus en plus
fréquents avec les populations de l'Est de
la Méditerranée amplifient le phénomène:
on retrouve la lèpre au nord de l'Angleterre
au IVe siècle, puis elle gagne la Scandinavie
et l'Islande via les raids vikings, et de
là elle atteint les pays baltes et la Russie.
En Méditerranée elle se répand aussi au
Maghreb, en Afrique de l'Ouest, et en Espagne
via les conquêtes musulmanes.
Et puis viennent les croisades et les pèlerinages
en Terre Sainte, qui, il est vrai, renforcent
l'incidence de la lèpre même si elle était
déjà présente en Europe. On estime qu'au
XIe siècle elle touche entre 0,2 et 0,8%
de la population, selon les historiens. On
ne peut donc pas vraiment parler d'épidémie.
Le mot «lèpre» vient du latin lepis,
qui signifie écaille en référence à la
peau des lépreux. Sa bactérie est identifiée
en 1873 par le médecin norvégien Hansen.
On l'appelle donc aussi «maladie de Hansen».
-À mon époque on parle de lepre, de leprosité
ou de meselerie.
-le mycobacterium leprae entraîne deux formes
de lèpre possible: la lèpre tuberculoïde,
non contagieuse, qui se traduit par une dépigmentation
de la peau, une insensibilité et des troubles
nerveux. La lèpre lépromateuse, de son côté,
est contagieuse par gouttelettes et entraîne
une plus forte atteinte cutanée, des lésions
et des nodules.
Ce sont les lépromateux qui transmettent
la maladie, et en meurent le plus. Heureusement
la lèpre est peu contagieuse: seuls 5%
des cas contacts la développent. Elle n'est
pas non plus héréditaire.
-A mon époque on connaissait déjà l'idée
de la contagion, mais on l'élargissait un
peu. Elle comprenait le contact avec un malade,
le fait de respirer le même air que lui,
de porter ses vêtements, mais aussi de croiser
son regard.
-Médusant.
-Toutefois cette maladie se développe lentement:
la bactérie peut incuber pendant cinq ans,
et les symptômes apparaître au bout de 25
à 30 ans, ainsi beaucoup de gens peuvent
être porteurs de la lèpre sans le savoir.
Dans certains cimetières anglais, les fouilles
montrent qu'au moins 19% des squelettes portaient
ses marques sans que ces personnes en aient
forcément été affectées de leur vivant.
Le discours médical sur la lèpre se met
en place au XIe siècle. Les signes principaux
retenus sont la difformité du visage, le
dessèchement de la peau, les pustules ou
nodules sur le corps, l'insensibilité nerveuse,
l'odeur, les ulcères, les mutilations, la
voix rauque, le nez rétracté... À un stade
avancé le malade peut perdre ses doigts et
ses orteils, son nez, ou devenir aveugle.
Les médecins comprennent que la lèpre n'est
pas qu'une maladie cutanée, qu'elle affecte
aussi le système nerveux au point de paralyser
les patients les plus atteints.
La sous-alimentation, le manque d'hygiène
dans les villes et les mauvaises conditions
météorologiques sont les principaux critères
qui fragilisent le métabolisme des hommes
du Moyen Âge et permettent la contagion.
La lèpre affecte particulièrement les pays
les plus froids, c'est-à-dire la Scandinavie
et la Grande-Bretagne.
Les traitements proposés visent surtout à
soulager mais non à guérir. On nettoie les
plaies, on utilise des purgatifs, des onguents,
des huiles... Tout en gardant à l'esprit
que cela ne sauvera pas le patient.
-Dans des cimetières de lépreux fouillés
au Danemark et en Allemagne, 80% des squelettes
correspondent aux critères de la lèpre,
ce qui montre l'efficacité des diagnostics
de l'époque.
Comme toutes les maladies ou événements
un peu hors du commun, la lèpre suscite un
tas de croyances parmi la population.
-Elle fut créée par le gouvernement et véhiculée
par la 5G.
-Non. On pense que la lèpre est une punition
divine individuelle, qui cible les menteurs,
les hérétiques...
-Certains avancent même que la lèpre se
transmet lors de rapports non permis, adultérins,
pendant les règles, ou avec des porcs. De
manière générale les lépreux sont vus
comme des pécheurs, des mauvais chrétiens,
et on leur attribue donc rapidement divers
crimes et délits. Ils empoisonneraient les
puits et fontaines, jetteraient des sorts...
À cause de cela ils sont de plus en plus
réprimés à la fin du Moyen Âge. Au XIIe
siècle certaines œuvres littéraires imaginent
que la lèpre peut être guérie par un bain
de sang humain, sûrement pour son apport
en fer, ce qui suffit à faire accuser les
ladres d'enlèvement d'enfants, de sorcellerie
et de commerce avec le diable.
-En 1321, dans le Sud de la France, une vague
de persécution se forme à leur encontre
à cause d'une croyance en un «complot
lépreux».
-On les accuse aussi, tout comme les juifs,
lors des grandes épidémies de pestes. Au
début du XVIe siècle Ambroise Paré écrit:
«Tous les ladres deviennent trompeurs,
furieux, lubriques».
Ces idées reçues sur les lépreux, en plus
de leur contagion, explique la volonté de
les isoler et de les exclure du monde qu'on
retrouve de plus en plus à la fin du Moyen
Âge. Ils ne doivent souiller les bons chrétiens
ni par leur maladie, ni par leurs vices.
-Mens sana in corpore sano.
-Pourtant, la vision de la lèpre est ambivalente.
Les lépreux sont aussi vus comme touchés
par la Justice divine, et donc choisis par
Dieu pour diffuser un message.
-«Le lépreux est celui que le Seigneur
a voulu visiter plus intimement que les autres».
C'est sale.
-On considère que les lépreux seront récompensés
après leur mort. Beaucoup de récits de miracles
mettent en scène des saints portant secours
à des lépreux, et Jésus lui-même en guérit.
Les malades se livrent donc à des prières,
confessions, pénitences et pèlerinages,
surtout sur les tombeaux des saints qui ont
eux-même soigné leurs semblables. Dès le
VIe siècle les tombeaux de Saint Martin de
Tours, de Saint Maixent ou de Saint Hilaire
de Poitiers sont très visités. D'autres
ladres se rendent carrément à Saint Jacques
de Compostelle ou en Terre Sainte à partir
du XIIe siècle, et tant pis s'ils diffusent
un peu plus leur maladie au passage.
Ces deux conceptions, du lépreux pêcheur
et du lépreux élu, vont de paire et incitent
les personnes saines à faire preuve de charité
et d'amour envers leur prochain malade.
Le sort des lépreux dans l'Ancien Testament
tend déjà vers une exclusion de la communauté:
«Le lépreux, atteint de la plaie, portera
ses vêtements déchirés, et aura la tête
nue; il se couvrira la barbe, et criera: Impur
! Impur ! Aussi longtemps qu’il aura la
plaie, il sera impur: il est impur. Il habitera
seul; sa demeure sera hors du camp.»
On constate pourtant que jusqu'au XIIIe siècle,
la lèpre n'entraîne pas nécessairement
une exclusion du monde des vivants. Quelques
édits et capitulaires du haut Moyen Âge
tentent de les isoler, dans d'autres sources
on retrouve des confiscations de biens, des
interdictions de voyager...
-La loi lombarde de Rotharic, au VIIe siècle,
prévoit que les lépreux doivent être expulsés
de leur ville et vivre dans la solitude.
-Outre ces exemples les lépreux peuvent continuer
de se marier, d'hériter, d'acheter et d'exercer
un métier. Certains occupent même des fonctions
de pouvoir, comme le comte Raoul de Vermandois
au XIIe siècle, Robert Bruce en Ecosse, ou
le roi Baudoin IV de Jérusalem qui meurt
des conséquences de sa maladie à 24 ans.
En 757, le pape Étienne II autorise la dissolution
de mariage si l'un des deux époux contracte
la lèpre, afin que l'autre puisse se remarier.
Dans certains cas cependant les époux restent
fidèles l'un à l'autre, ou la personne saine
accompagne son ou sa conjointe s'il doit entrer
en léproserie. Cette exception est brièvement
levée au XIIe siècle, l'Église étant réticente
à casser l'un de ses sacrements, mais les
annulations de mariage sont ré-autorisées
au XIIIe siècle. Elles ne sont jamais automatiques,
le conjoint sain peut la réclamer s'il le
souhaite.
La situation évolue donc au XIIIe siècle.
En 1179, le concile de Latran III énonce
que tous les lépreux perdent leur statut
juridique et doivent être séparés de leur
communauté d'origine, pour rejoindre des
léproseries que nous aborderons bientôt.
Pour cela, il fallait d'abord s'assurer que
le malade l'était bien, aussi bien pour éviter
les erreurs médicales que les dépenses inutiles
s'il était placé à tord en léproserie.
L'Église encourage les dénonciations à
partir du XIIIe siècle, tout en punissant
les abus.
-Envoyer un voisin ou un proche à la léproserie
peut être un bon moyen de s'approprier ses
biens...
-Le malade présumé est examiné par un médecin
qui cherche les signes de la lèpre. Selon
les régions il teste son sang, examine la
couleur de son visage, la qualité de ses
poils et cheveux, ses narines, sa bouche,
son haleine, teste sa sensibilité nerveuse...
Dans certaines villes comme à Reims, ce sont
des lépreux qui examinent les malades présumés
car ils sont jugés plus à même de connaître
les signes de la maladie.
-Toi tu vis, toi tu vis, toi tu meurs
-Par contre ils avaient aussi souvent tendance
à reconnaître saines des personnes malades,
pour éviter d'avoir une bouche de plus à
nourrir à la léproserie.
-Un jury médical rend ensuite son verdict.
Quel que soit le résultat de l'examen, c'est
au patient de régler les frais de la procédure
judiciaire. Dans certains cas il est déclaré
pouvant devenir ladre, il est alors maintenu
dans sa communauté sous surveillance. Dans
les cas où la lèpre est avérée, il doit
entrer en léproserie.
Cette séparation ne se fait pas sans une
cérémonie religieuse, la lèpre étant toujours
vue comme une punition divine, plus ou moins
présente et codifiée selon les régions.
Le malade est conduit de sa maison à l'église
sur un brancard, couvert d'un drap mortuaire.
Une messe est donnée, on prie beaucoup, et
dans certains cas le prêtre jette quelques
pelletées de terre du cimetière sur le ladre
en disant «tu es mort au monde». Dans
d'autres endroits le malade était carrément
descendu dans une fosse. Sympathique.
Le lépreux reçoit ensuite son nouvel habit:
une tunique avec un morceau d'étoffe, souvent
rouge, sur la poitrine, des gants, une écuelle
pour l'aumône et des cliquettes. Ses biens
d'avant sont soit brûlés, soit offerts à
la léproserie qui l'accueille et vers laquelle
il est ensuite conduit en procession.
Depuis le VIe siècle, on considère que c'est
à l'Église de porter assistance aux lépreux.
En ville c'est l'évêque qui s'en charge,
et dans les campagnes c'est plutôt le rôle
des prêtres et des habitants. Les ladres
ne sont pas encore isolés en groupe mais
peuvent vivre dans des petites cabanes loin
des autres. Cette prise en charge par l'Église
pose problème car toutes les collectivités
n'ont pas les même moyens: certaines acceptent
donc d'aider les lépreux de leur secteur
mais chassent ceux qui ne sont pas du coin.
-C'est l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité.
-À l'époque des croisades, les choses évoluent.
Des léproseries sont créées à Jérusalem
et en 1120 est fondé l'ordre de Saint-Lazare,
le saint protecteur des lépreux. Il s'agit
d'un ordre hospitalier et militaire dont les
membres sont tous lépreux, du moins au début,
et se consacrent aux soins de leurs semblables.
Ils arrivent en Europe à partir de 1154 et
donnent le terme de «lazaret», un lieu
de quarantaine pour ladres.
-Comme la lèpre fait un bond en avant au
XIIe siècle, l'isolement des malades devient
de plus en plus nécessaire. Les plus riches,
par charité, font donc créer des léproseries
un peu partout en Europe.
-Le nombre de ces léproseries est sujet à
débat: les premiers chiffres parlent de
20 000 en Europe dont 2000 en France, voire
4000 selon d'autres historiens. Le problème
est qu'on manque de sources pour les compter:
la principale est le testament de Louis VIII,
en 1226, où il déclare léguer 100 sous
aux 2000 léproseries du royaume.
-Le truc c'est que la taille des léproseries
était trèèès variable, d'une simple hutte
individuelle à des léproseries pouvant accueillir
200 malades comme à Chartres. Et même là,
on trouvait rarement plus de trente lépreux
dans les locaux.
-De plus le fait que le roi parle de 2000
léproseries, un chiffre rond, tend à montrer
qu'aucun inventaire précis n'existait.
Pour ce qui est des 20 000 léproseries en
Europe il s'agit d'un chiffre mal interprété
et donné par Matthieu Paris, un moine bénédictin
du XIIIe siècle. Il parlait en fait de 19
000 maisons de l'ordre des Hospitaliers, et
non de 19 000 léproseries. L'erreur est expliquée
en 1891 mais continue d'être véhiculée.
Des enquêtes plus locales parlent de 100
léproseries dans l'Aisne, 170 dans le Sud-Ouest,
mais sans qu'il soit possible de trouver toutes
leurs dates de fondation et de fin.
La plupart des léproseries sont créées
entre 1150 et 1270 et il est probable qu'il
y ait en ait eu un peu trop par rapport au
nombre de malades.
-Énormément de léproseries sont créées
et entretenues par donation, parce que ça
fait bien pour les seigneurs, c'est une sorte
d'investissement pour l'au-delà.
-Robert d'Arbrissel, le fondateur de l'abbaye
de Fontevraud, demande à se faire enterrer
dans le bâtiment des lépreux au milieu de
ses «enfants chéris». Les léproseries
sont aussi souvent citées dans les testaments.
Comment fonctionnent donc ces léproseries?
Les plus rurales sont implantées à l'écart
des agglomérations et se composent de plusieurs
maisons ou cabanes individuelles regroupées
autour d'une chapelle. Les lépreux y avaient
un mobilier et un secours très réduit. Pour
créer une léproserie on faisait attention
à l'exposition au vent. Elles sont donc souvent
au Sud-Est des villages, proches d'une rivière
ou d'une fontaine, et près d'une voie de
circulation pour que les malades puissent
faire l'aumône. Elles ne doivent pas non
plus être trop éloignées de la ville, pour
les même raisons.
La plupart des grandes villes se dotent donc
de léproseries à l'extérieur de leurs murs,
d'autres sont intégrées aux monastères
dans des locaux séparés. Quoi qu'il en soit
les léproseries sont généralement supervisées
par des moines, surtout de l'ordre de Saint
Lazare. On y trouve aussi des personnes valides
qui se «donnent» à la léproserie et
se consacrent aux soins des malades par charité.
Leur entrée en léproserie est payante, en
nature ou en monnaie, afin d'assurer l'entretien
des lieux. Ils font dès lors vœu de chasteté
et de servir les pauvres, presque comme des
moines, et renoncent à leurs biens.
Pour les malades, l'entrée en léproserie
se faisait après un examen médical, une
décision judiciaire et souvent une cérémonie
religieuse, comme on l'a vu. Les ladres les
plus riches devaient payer un droit d'entrée
pour venir y vivre, en monnaie ou en mobilier
voire les deux.
-À Marseille, tout lépreux doit apporter
son lits, ses draps, le ménage qui lui sera
nécessaire et un peu d'argent.
-À Nîmes, les nouveaux malades doivent payer
15 livres tournois s'ils sont de la ville
et 25 s'ils viennent de l'extérieur, et doivent
encore amener leurs propres affaires. Les
pauvres sont reçus sans payer. La plupart
du temps on trouvait 5 à 8 malades dans chaque
léproserie, exceptionnellement une vingtaine
ou plus. Leur espérance de vie y était de
trois à cinq ans, avec là encore des exceptions.
À Haguenau, un malade passe 22 ans dans sa
léproserie.
La vie en communauté implique des règles:
les malades sont régis par celle de saint
Augustin, comme dans les hôpitaux. On y trouve
des rituels spécifiques, comme les fêtes
d'entrée des nouveaux venus et les processions
dans les dortoirs pour asperger les malades
d'eau bénite. Les lépreux sont autorisés
à participer à des foires, à voyager entre
léproseries et à effectuer des pèlerinages.
Ils peuvent aussi voir leur famille et celle-ci
peut leur rendre visite. Le reste de leur
temps est consacré à la liturgie.
-Les lépreux sont bien nourris: la léproserie
de Beaulieu propose par exemple du porc, du
bœuf, du mouton et du potage, voire du poisson,
du poulet, du fromage et des œufs en temps
de fête. Plutôt riche pour l'époque.
-Eh bien voilà, tu as trouvé ta vocation.
-Le fait qu'ils soient placés en léproserie
ne signifie pas qu'on renonce à les soigner,
contrairement à certaines croyances anciennes.
Ce ne sont en aucun cas des mouroirs. Les
médecins cherchent à ralentir le mal par
des bains, des onguents, des fumigations,
des cataplasmes, des ventouses... Ils ont
bien conscience qu'on ne guérit pas de la
lèpre mais cherchent surtout à soulager
le mal de leurs patients.
Il existe une grande différence entre les
lépreux admis dans des institutions aux ressources
importantes, bénéficiant de dons, et ceux
qui se retrouvent dans des «hameaux de
lépreux» sans moyen de subsistance. La
léproserie de Narbonne, par exemple, est
un acteur économique important de la région
grâce à son patrimoine foncier et à ses
investissements. Les autres malades, ceux
qui ne trouvent pas de bonnes places, ont
le droit de cultiver leur terre, de vendre
leurs produits. Beaucoup fabriquent des cordages
de bateaux, un métier qui leur est réservé.
Et pour les autres, il reste la quête.
-Les ladres sont autorisés à sortir de leur
léproserie pour l'aumône, selon des règles
diverses selon les villes: à certaines
périodes de l'année seulement, pendant les
fêtes religieuses, à certaines heures, dans
des endroits précis... Ils n'ont pas le droit
de manger ou boire en ville, ni de découcher.
-Tant qu'ils peuvent aller s'acheter des paquets
de pâtes, je ne vois pas le problème.
-Contrairement aux croyances, la cliquette
du lépreux ne lui sert pas à faire fuir
les personnes saines qui l'entourent mais
à faire l'aumône. C'est un instrument constitué
d'une tablette en bois, sur laquelle deux
petites planches viennent frapper. Puisque
la maladie touche les cordes vocales, elle
permet d'appeler les passants sans s'user
inutilement, et de leur signaler qu'il y a
un lépreux pas loin qui mendie.
D'autres lépreux ne sont pas intégrés à
des léproseries, ce qui rend le nombre des
malades d'autant plus difficile à établir.
Il s'agit de lépreux nomades, échappés
ou exclus de leur institution, ou bien qui
n'avaient pas les moyens ou ont refusé d'y
entrer. Ce sont ceux qui inquiètent le plus
la population car ils sont incontrôlables,
ils transmettent la maladie et ont parfois
recours au vol pour vivre.
À mesure que les ladres sont invités à
entrer en léproserie, des interdits à leur
encontre voient le jour. Selon les villes
ils ne peuvent plus entrer à l'église, dans
les lieux publics ou les marchés, s'approcher
des fontaines, des enfants, manger avec des
personnes saines ou même toucher de la nourriture
en dehors de celle qu'ils ont achetée, se
déplacer sans leur habit spécifique, parler
à quelqu'un sans se mettre sous le vent,
circuler dans les rues étroites... La ville
de Lille est interdite d'accès aux lépreux
à partir de 1239. À Périgueux, ils peuvent
traverser la ville sans y séjourner. À Salon,
les ladres peuvent se déplacer librement
même au marché puisqu'ils ont juste l'interdiction
de toucher les aliments qu'on y vend.
Malgré ces interdits les lépreux sont donc
plus ou moins intégrés à la société,
contrairement à ce que les historiens pensaient
auparavant.
-Ils vivent en reclus, non en exclus.
-Errare humanus est.
-L'attitude à leur égard se durcit surtout
à partir du XIIIe siècle, on voit que de
nombreux règlements de villes sont pris à
cette période. Ce durcissement correspond
à une évolution des mentalités à la fin
du Moyen Âge. La société change d'attitude
vis à vis des minorités, on pense qu'elles
vont à l'encontre de l'unité tant recherchée.
Pour les gens de la fin du Moyen Âge, la
diversité, c'est le mal.
-Quelle tolérance.
-Parce que vos périodes sont mieux peut-être?
-On retrouve ce changement de mentalité dans
le domaine de la religion, mais aussi dans
le droit. De ce fait ce sont les ladres errants
qui sont les plus stigmatisés, au même titre
que toutes les populations marginales: les
mendiants, animaux errants, prostituées...
Les léproseries établies depuis longtemps
et intégrées à leur territoire restent
mieux tolérées.
C'est aussi à partir de cette époque que
le rituel d'entrée en léproserie prend la
forme d'une sorte d'enterrement, comme on
l'a vu. Auparavant, l'idée était plutôt
d'organiser une cérémonie d'entrée en religion.
L'autre raison de ce durcissement est la préoccupation
de plus en plus grande pour la santé publique,
surtout au XIVe siècle puisque la peste apparaît
en Occident. La question de la contagion devient
plus importante et on fuit les contacts.
Des procès sont aussi organisés contre les
«faux lépreux» qui vivraient de la
charité ou essaieraient d'entrer en léproserie
pour y couler des jours tranquilles. En 1321,
une vague de persécutions à l'encontre des
lépreux court dans le Sud de la France et
en conduit un grand nombre au bûcher. L'ordonnance
royale de 1371 ordonne aux ladres vagabonds
de Paris de rejoindre leur léproserie sans
délai. À Avignon, au XVe siècle, la ville
verse un droit à sa léproserie pour que
ses occupants n'en sortent pas et les malades
étrangers sont refoulés par des «chasseurs
de lépreux» recrutés par la municipalité.
Entre les progrès de l'hygiène, la fin des
croisades et la persécution de plus en plus
grande dont ils sont victimes, et qui les
exclut davantage de la société quand ils
ne sont pas carrément tués, le nombre de
ladres diminue au XIVe siècle. D'abord dans
le Nord de la France puis en descendant vers
le Sud. L'ordre des chevaliers de Saint Lazare
est dissout à la fin du XVe siècle. Au milieu
du XVIe siècle la maladie est considérée
comme vaincue en Europe, les léproseries
sont presque vides. Elles sont données en
1672 à l'ordre restauré de Saint Lazare
et du Mont Carmel, un ordre religieux qui
n'a plus de rapport avec le soin des lépreux.
La lèpre ne disparaît pas totalement en
Europe: on en trouve encore quelques cas
en France, en Espagne et en Norvège au XIXe
siècle. Le sanatorium de Fontilles, dans
la province de Valence, accueille de nombreux
malades entre 1909 et 1980. Les dernières
léproseries d'Europe ferment à cette période,
les quelques cas détectés chaque année
étant pris en charge individuellement. Le
premier traitement contre la lèpre est mis
en place en 1944 et a été amélioré depuis.
Il ne faut pas oublier l'outre-mer, puisqu'on
trouve encore des foyers de lèpre à Mayotte,
ramenée par les Comores, et en Guyane à
cause de la frontière brésilienne.
Si les léproseries européennes sont transformées
en musées et lieux de mémoire, dans le reste
du monde la maladie n'a pas disparu. Déjà
parce que les continents se sont refilé le
bacille allègrement: l'Europe et l'Inde
ont contaminé la Chine via la route de la
soie, la colonisation européenne a contaminé
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et l'Amérique... La
première léproserie d'Amérique est fondée
par Cortès lui-même, pour les conquistadors
malades uniquement. Sur ce continent la lèpre
a été transmise au tatou, seul autre animal
que l'homme à en être atteint, et qui transmet
à son tour la maladie aux humains. Extrait
Molokai
Les pays touchés prennent des mesures diverses
contre cette maladie, souvent sévères et
raciales: le Japon pratique la castration
forcée jusqu'en 1996. En Australie, après
la contamination d'un citoyen par un aborigène
en 1892, il est interdit auxdits aborigènes
de franchir le 30e parallèle qui prend alors
le nom de «leper line».
De nos jours les principaux foyers de la lèpre
sont l'Inde, le Brésil, le Népal, l'Indonésie...
On comptait 230 000 nouveaux malades dans
le monde en 2012, des chiffres toutefois en
forte diminution depuis le début du XXIe
siècle, et un total variant selon les études
entre 3 et 10 millions de lépreux. S'il existe
maintenant un traitement, il n'y a toujours
pas de vaccin contre cette maladie. Ses malades
continuent de véhiculer une image négative,
qui oblige le Conseil des Droits de l'Homme
à rappeler en 2008: «Toute personne
atteinte de la lèpre ainsi que les membres
de leur famille doivent être traités avec
dignité comme des individus et sont en droit
de bénéficier des droits et des libertés
fondamentaux
de
la personne humaine».